pierre roche emmanuel macron prône
depuis le début de son mandat à la
création d'une défense européenne
une des qui ne fait pas du tout
l'unanimité un parmi les 27 est ce que
justement cette guerre en ukraine va
changer la donne déjà on peut dire que
la précédente guerre en ukraine en 2014
avait déjà joué un grand rôle dans la
relance de cette idée il ya eu des
initiatives la défense européenne c'est
pas forcément le domaine du grand soir
immédiat mais c'est des initiatives qui
s'ajoute la commission européenne s'est
mis à investir une partie de son budget
sur les questions de défense il y a eu
la coopération structurée permanente
entre les états membres qui lancé des
projets plus ambitieux en matière de
défense il ya eu des initiatives et
c'est sûr qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya une
crise non seulement ça augmente l'idée
que ça renforce l'idée qu'il faut faire
quelque chose en matière de défense et
puis ça renforce aussi psychologiquement
la cohésion de l'europe puisque c'est ce
qu'on voit là c'est pas du tout une
crise qui divise les européens c'est une
crise qui les incite plutôt à faire à
faire bloc donc c'est sûr que ça ça
renforce ce débat oui l'allemagne a
débloqué plusieurs milliards d'euros
pour développer son art mais c'était
inimaginable il ya encore quelques
années qu'est ce qui est en train de
changer la en europe avec cette nouvelle
l'allemagne c'est un cas très
intéressant parce que c'est un pays qui
a eu une attitude ils ont un peu ambigu
toujours très favorable à l'otan
alliance atlantique à la défense de
l'europe à l'union européenne et en même
temps avec un parti russophiles disons
assez influent des intérêts commerciaux
importants avec le gaz avec la russie
l'idée qu'il fallait un peu séparer les
enjeux économiques et politiques pour
essayer de ils ont ménagé la chèvre et
le chou et la finalement cette crise a
mis l'allemagne au pied du mur est
clairement le choix qui a été fait c'est
de choisir la sécurité choisir la
cohésion occidentale au détriment de ce
parti pro russe qui est très affaiblie
aujourd'hui donc ça ça c'est un c'est un
illustrateur de ce qui est en train de
changer et on le voit dans d'autres pays
aussi européens où ce qui était plus
favorable à la russie sont sont plus mal
à l'aise forcément